it's great to welcome to the program
today Daniel M Irv R who is teaching
history at Northwestern University also
is the author of the recent book how to
hide an empire a history of the greater
United States Daniel thanks for joining
me first of all I think this is such an
important topic right now for a few
different reasons number one just
understanding the history of the United
States is something that we would all be
better served to do and I think we would
be bought all better off if more people
understood it in in some degree of
detail but specifically when it comes to
Empire and the misconceptions that many
people have about the history of
American Empire and also some of the
confusions between Empire and
colonialism I think that it's a
particularly important topic now give us
a sort of entryway into the topic as
your book describes it how far back do
we need to go to start developing our
understanding of American Empire I think
you need to go all the way back to the
beginning from the day that the country
receives its independence from Great
Britain from the day that that treaty is
ratified the United States despite its
name the United States of America isn't
just a union of states it's a union of
states and territories that's what it is
on day one that's what it is today and
that's what it's been on every
intervening day more to the point the
official name of the country is the
United States of America but for most of
the country's history it also hasn't
been was limited to North America since
1857 the country's borders have extended
into the Caribbean and into the Pacific
so I think if you really want to
understand US history you need to
understand the full scope of the United
States and you need to understand that
that means not just looking at the
States not just looking at the
contiguous blob but looking at the US
Empire yeah so let's start maybe a
little bit with the islands in the
Pacific and the Caribbean and
interestingly the role that that guano
or bird poop plays in all of this and if
people of my generation I think we hear
the word guano and they think of Jim
Carrey and they think of one of those
Ace Ventura movies where we're good
the first time I was exposed to guano
when I was like nine years old or
something like that but this is actually
not just a joke from a Jim Carrey movie
this is actually connected to a lot of
really important historical issues for
the United States in the Caribbean and
in the Pacific how did how does that
work what's the role of guano yeah so
let's talk about what guano is guano is
either bat or bird feces that's used as
fertilizer and in the nineteenth century
as farms in the United States were
experiencing what farmers then called
soil exhaustion losing a lot of
nutrients as they transition to
industrial agriculture but didn't yet
have the chemical fertilizers that we
have they found that they were
encountering decreasing yields in such a
way that it was a major looming economic
crisis the one thing that worked that
worked really well was guano and
particularly bird droppings from sea
islands so you have to imagine these
islands sort of surrounded by large
bodies of water small islands and birds
congregate on them and then you know
over the years over the centuries the
bird droppings concentrated on these
small islands accumulate pile high into
the Sun bake in the Sun this works best
on islands where there's very little
rain and you know sort of the very rock
of the island itself is calcified bird
droppings
Beth stuff is tremendous for farms and
there's a sort of land rush in the
nineteenth century for the United States
to claim as many uninhabited guano
islands as a Ken so over the course of
the second half of the nineteenth
century and this is its first form of
overseas expansion the United States
claims nearly 100 guano islands in the
Pacific and in the Caribbean so now
there's a very particular political
divide on the concept of American Empire
and a lot of that divide splits pretty
cleanly depending on where one sort of
is on the political spectrum in thinking
back to the the guano era so to speak
and the time where we were seeing
westward expansion within the what is
now the contiguous 48 states in the 19th
century the
expansion was starting into the
Caribbean in Pacific Islands was there
an equivalent political split amongst
the population in terms of who supported
this island expansion and who did not or
were political circumstances different
such that that debate wasn't really
taking place no there really was a
debate throughout the 19th century as
the United States as borders expanded
westward even before it started to
expand overseas expansion was
contentious and generally the two poles
of contention not the only ones but the
main ones were between expansionist who
wanted to see the borders of the United
States grow and who wanted to claim new
lands for the for the country and
racists who were concerned about
incorporating too many people who were
perceived as non-white into the Union so
it's an interesting moment when the
United States expands quite a lot over
the course of the 19th century but
actually doesn't incorporate a large
number of people as a percentage of its
own population and a lot of the borders
of the United States when it's expanding
in the 19th century are carefully
curated so the United States can claim
for example as much of Mexico as it can
get while still claiming as few Mexicans
as it can and this comes up in the
debate about the guano Islands one thing
that gets that guano Islands act through
Congress is the proviso that any guano
islands that are claims the United
States has to be uninhabited so this can
be land that can be added to the United
States and new locations that will be
part of the United States but they won't
bring new peoples into the Union so the
idea of the peoples into the Union is
interesting because one of the things
that I I would argue and you might agree
you might disagree has sort of changed
in the conversation about American
Empire since the 1800s that that you and
I have been talking about so far is that
I think today one of the most sort of
important elements of American Empire is
socio-cultural empire the idea of music
movies television literature when I go
and visit I was born in Argentina when I
go visit my family in Argentina there's
an awareness of that
Bread of American Empire that is not
reciprocal in the United States from
most other countries what is your sense
of the importance of that today is it a
form of empire and when did this sort of
start to shift would you say yes oh
there's a debate now about whether it's
proper to characterize the United States
as an empire and there are a lot of
aspects that you could note if you
wanted to make that argument one is the
extent of US culture and the way that
that's non-reciprocal that if you're in
Argentina you end up knowing a lot more
about US music and if you're in the
United States and you're thinking about
Argentinian music it's also in terms of
the USS military involvement in dozens
of countries you know at any one time
around the world the polite term for
this or the positive term for this would
be influence leadership a critical or
negative term often used as a pejorative
would be Empire margin is a little
different it's not about whether the
United States is behaving badly is
imposing itself on other countries I
just followed the territory and I just
looked at the territorial shape of the
United States and make a fairly obvious
you know observation that the United
States has had territories and
particularly overseas territories for
the bulk of its history so in that sort
of analytical sense it's it's just you
know on the map the United States is an
empire and I think it's that's important
to note because the territorial extent
of the United States has often been
important into supporting the other
kinds of influence or power extension or
empire that the United States has been
able to exert in the world particularly
in the last 50 or 60 years yeah I think
the debate is interesting even within
the sort of space on the Left that I
occupy in my program occupies because I
think that you can first of all it's
perfectly fair to make a critique in
terms of what ought or should be
American foreign policy and that that's
a great conversation to have but I do
think some of the areas of sort of
question in terms of modern Empire would
be you often hear about the military
presence of the United States around the
world it's a very important thing but I
do think we have to consider in that
that for the most part the US is in
places where we're invited to be
a lot of it is also connected to shared
defense agreements that may be in place
so what when I think about this as a
progressive I still do think it's
important to pay attention to are we
imposing our political and cultural
system in places where the military is
for example and I think that there's
sort of more to it than just how far
does the reach of the military exist I
don't know where you would fall on that
no I think that's right my sense is that
since World War two the United States is
sought to pursue a different strategy
for exerting itself in the world
it's tended to distant or try to
distance itself from colonial empire
that doesn't mean that the United States
no longer has territories it does and
millions of people live in them but
nevertheless the United States has
declined to take large populated
colonies at times when it could have you
know it fought the Vietnam War and at no
point did it try to annex Vietnam or
earlier Korea or later Iraq nevertheless
the United States has instead try to
sort of claim what I call a pointillist
empire lots of little dots that are
particularly designed to allow the
United States to with invitation move
its forces do all kinds of things that
it needs to do without ensconcing large
population so I think there's a real
difference to the kind of projection of
power in a sort of territorial footprint
of the United States today and the sort
of large-scale territorial Empire of say
the British in the nineteenth century or
even the United States in the early 20th
century yeah well I was going to ask
about that next and you're alluding to
some of the differences already what his
store I mean I know this has just
shifted over time in ways we've
described already with regard to
American influence and Empire around the
world but are there any larger systemic
or structural differences in general
that you would point to when we think
about the history of American Empire
versus for example British French or
Spanish yeah I think that the current
day us territorial Empire the big
difference is it's a version to sort of
engrossing large colonized populations
the British were quite proud of the you
know hundreds of millions of colonial
subjects over whom they ruled and that
was part of it the British had
holiday called Empire day celebrating
this and schoolchildren would sort of
gaze was you know reverently at the map
and dress in national costume of people
from all the colonies that's both never
been really a part of the United States
colonial tradition even at a time when
it had a fairly even more populous
colonial empire than it did today and
also it doesn't seem to me the
trajectory of the United States is
territorial Empire it's it's more and
more just you know pursuing places that
are far from populations where the its
military bases will less likely grade up
against local populations and produce
resistance often it seeks to station its
forces on islands where it can or you
know on ships in the middle of the sea
where there's really no local population
so I think that that's a huge difference
between how territorial empires
practiced today and how it used to be
practiced in the nineteenth century and
is that there's the same or a similar
analysis apply to Spain and France yeah
I think that's right yeah I think the
big shift is not the sort of flavor of
imperialist the big shift is a shift
away from large colonial empires and
that's a pattern in which the United
States was a participant never as large
as Britain but actually by the end of
World War Two was the fourth largest
empire by population on the planet
within after World War Two you see a
shift led by the United States toward
what I call it pointillist Empire let's
talk now maybe about some more micro
issues related to territories today and
we could talk about Puerto Rico we could
talk about Guam or other places the
political debate around those
territories is almost exclusively
focused around the possibility of
statehood and typically there's a sort
of partisan interpretation that a lot of
these places are more than likely to
become left-leaning or what we would
call Democratic with regard to electoral
politics and thus there's this
assumption that Democrats would be more
likely to favor statehood for some of
these territories Republicans would be
more likely to oppose it number one is
that actually is that actually an
important consideration when we evaluate
what should happen with these
territories and number two what do you
think are the sort of primary issues
today related to these territories
around the world
yeah I don't think that the predicted
political leanings of territories were
they could become stage should be the
determining issue that just turns the
question of status in you know just
turns the territories into pawns in a
mainland political game and I think that
you know for me the history of us Empire
has really just driven home how awful
and sometimes lethal I can be to regard
the territories as you know me and
insofar as how they serve the interest
of mainlanders really I the status
question is really complicated because
it's not just a question about Rights
it's also a question about identity
economically berto Rico would in some
ways benefit from becoming a state there
are really good cultural reasons why a
lot of Puerto Ricans resist the notion
of statement there are also really good
cultural reasons why a lot of them are
excited about it or at least
acquiescence to it but ultimately I
think that's a decision that needs to be
made by the inhabitants of the
territories I mean this cannot be just
we cannot continue this history which
has gone on for more than a century of
the political status of territories
being determined by people who don't
live in the territories we've been
talking mostly about the book how to
hide an empire a history of the greater
United States the book's author has been
speaking with me he is Daniel M revoir
teaching history at Northwestern
University Daniel really a pleasure
having you on today pleasure being here